Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Io sono questo strumento.
Manca ancora qualcosa
perché io possa farlo,
ma arriviamo tra un attimo.
Ci sono dei musicologi che dicono
che la prima volta, in tempi preistorici,
quando un uomo ha scagliato
la prima freccia e ha teso un arco,
ha inventato l'arpa,
che è l’Arco musicale.
Ecco: questo strumento, ovviamente,
lancia suoni, non lancia frecce.
Suoni che possono commuovere.
Nella storia abbiamo Orfeo,
che mitiga gli animali,
Davide, che mitiga l'animo dell'uomo.
E sono eccezioni dell'arte.
Ma a tutt’oggi lo strumento, in pratica,
conserva questa sua anima primitiva.
Ma cosa succederebbe se noi, invece,
volessimo cambiare la sua immagine?
Che è molto standardizzata,
perché tutti abbiamo
un immagine dell'arpa,
essendo così unita alla storia dell'uomo?
Eh, succedono delle cose particolari.
La prima è che muoviamo la mente,
cambiamo la nostra immagine,
e questo è sempre interessante.
La seconda cosa, invece,
è quella di lavorare sul suono,
e quindi spostare un po' più in là
il suono che voi avete in mente
o che avete sempre sentito
dello strumento.
Ed è quello che sono qui a fare oggi,
mostrare cosa succederebbe
se si uniscono delle cose
antiche e moderne,
e quali sono le differenze.
Sul suono è bello lavorare,
perché è la materia
di cui siamo fatti, anche, credo, noi.
La vibrazione è l'universo, è il tutto.
E quindi il musicista
ha una grande responsabilità
a maneggiare questa cosa.
E il primo brano che vi suono,
infatti, è proprio su questo.
Si intitola: “Tempio del suono”.
È un brano di Roberto Cacciapaglia,
lui lavora molto
su questa accezione magica,
sul potere del suono.
Cercherò di farlo anch'io,
con la mia visione di questo brano.
E quindi vi invito
ad entrare nel tempio del suono.
(Applausi)
Grazie.
Sempre per “What If..”
c'è anche un altro brano.
È un "What If..." un po' diverso
da quello di prima,
nel senso che qui si parla
di un brano molto famoso del '900:
“Adagio for strings”, di Samuel Barber.
È un brano che penso sia incluso
in tutti i “Best-of” di musica classica.
E qualche anno fa, però,
un DJ olandese, che è uno
dei più famosi al mondo,
si chiama DJ Tiësto,
ne ha fatto una versione pop.
E così un brano
di musica classica per archi
è diventato uno, è stato proprio votato,
come uno dei brani dance
più belli di sempre.
Ecco, io ho pensato di farvene
una versione per arpa.
Che mi sembra uno strumento
molto dance, come potete vedere.
(Applausi)